moviegoers got their first look at
chadwick boseman as black panther two
years ago when he appeared in Marvel
Studios Captain America Civil War the
comic-book character was created in 1966
and was the first black superhero to go
mainstream now Black Panther will have
his own standalone movie opening
nationwide next week and as brook
silva-braga tells us the new movie is
doing more than just breaking box-office
records
good morning Brooke good morning though
it is indeed doing very well at the box
office fan Daigo actually says it has
the strongest advance sales of any
superhero movie they've tracked it also
has the best sales of any movie released
in the first quarter of the year and
that's being seen as an early
endorsement of a film that embraces
african-american talent in front of and
behind the camera in a way that many
have been waiting for for a long long
time this is why people get to feel all
the time just the movie poster was
enough for some fans to embrace Black
Panther but now as critical praise
builds and social media buzz flows a
superhero movie with a black director
and mostly black cast is being hailed as
something bigger it's a cultural moment
in fandango's Chris Witherspoon sees the
movie of a heroic King and his wealthy
futuristic African nation as a new
moment for Hollywood this film's unlike
any superhero film have you ever seen
it's it's a diverse story that it's long
overdue and there's this social media
movement that's happening that I think
is galvanizing ticket sells like we
never have seen before
that includes the Black Panther
challenge a viral online fundraising
effort that started with plans to help
kids in Harlem see the movie I recently
tweeted out a GoFundMe page that was
started as a way to take deserving kids
to see the upcoming movie black panther
with a nudge from Ellen DeGeneres it's
mushroomed to include more than 300
fundraisers poised to send tens of
thousands of young fans to the theater
Jameel smith wrote about the film for a
time magazine cover story I think
there's going to be a five year old kid
who walks into a theater
and says wow I can be T'Challa
I can be shorty I can be AK way I can be
all these different wonderful characters
that you see in this film and critics
say it's good scoring an almost unheard
of 99% rating from Rotten Tomatoes which
averages movie reviews this is a story
that is not only interesting and
compelling and well told it's also fun
you know what I mean and that's the
thing that people maybe get lost with
all this sort of you know preoccupation
with politics and race and all the buzz
is already stoking speculation a sequel
could be on the way so you can be
forgiven for forgetting that Black
Panthers still won't hit theaters until
next Friday
Wow it's good box-office good for the
culture and society to have more people
of color on screen this film proves that
doesn't it yeah people are excited for
about it for different reasons but a lot
of people are genuinely excited I'm
excited because it looks like it's a
good night looks like a great movie and
Chadwick Boseman is awesome right who's
where the director is awesome all-star
cast
all right brook silva-braga thanks